good morning thanks for joining us this
morning thanks for coming in uh let's
talk waiting list of shots to start with
should we um
they are going to perhaps double over
the next two years until march of
2024 your manifesto said that you were
going to be there when patients needed
you now what happened um the pandemic
happened is the short answer okay we
knew that we had challenged with waiting
lists before the pandemic that's why our
manifesto commitment was clear but we've
had two years of huge disruption
to our nhs as it both tackled the
pandemic but also as it wasn't able to
do as many routine or normal procedures
as it normally would and that figure you
talked about about the waiting list um
going up there's about well just around
six million people on the waiting list
there's around eight and a half million
who we would normally expect to have
come forward over the past two years who
haven't and therefore we've got to make
an assessment that many of them will now
start coming forward so we should expect
here as the secretary of state says that
is going up before we can bring it down
but we've set out the plan to do that um
this week one in ten people presently on
an nhs waiting list right now
it's actually it's around one in nine
people on the on the waiting list i
always straight with you and your
viewers okay about this i think it's one
in five in wales that's a huge figure
and every one of those people will
understandably
be concerned they'll either be in pain
or they'll be and somebody anxious about
wanting to find out about 75
of those in the on the waiting list are
not on the waiting list for actual
treatment they're on it for things like
diagnostic tests in the large part and
they will be people who don't know um
what their situation so understand that
they'll be very anxious that's why we're
investing heavily in diagnostics because
people want to know whether they're okay
or whether they do need to have
treatment and people can move around the
country to have treatment that has been
the case for some time but people
haven't been doing that obviously
because of the pandemic but even before
that they won't so how did they find out
how to do that well there's a number of
uh ways we're doing that first one and i
think
my boss secretary of state i think was
on with you earlier he was this week my
planned care is one of those
uh one of those mechanisms online people
being able to see waiting times at
different hospitals to the nhs you'll be
able to we're developing that uh that
system as we speak so it's not
dependable yet not there yet he wanted
to be open with people that's a key part
of the plan
but equally as part of that plan we're
working with the nhs with a national
coordination team who will work with
clinicians who will be able to give
people more information and options
where they may want to stay local but
there may be a longer wait for that
particular specialty in their hospital
but they may be able to go around the
country the nhs is putting in place that
plan to help move people around with
things like transport but it's not but
also no it's not there the secretary of
state set out the plan for this and that
will come on stream later this year
it's a part of that plan we've already
started though i know there was a lot of
speculation on monday saying well where
is the plan does this mean that we're
delaying helping people no it doesn't
because we've already announced for
example the diagnostic centers
diagnostic hubs which are already up and
running and i think 60 or 70 different
places so we haven't waited but this
plan sets out that longer term approach
and crucially some of those targets and
those trajectories for trying to bring
that waiting list back down
march 2024 is when we can see the
waiting list start to fall that's
perilously closed for a government given
that the election is in may of that year
well i think kay what's important with
this plan and you're sitting you're
seeing some of the comments i think from
some of the nhs leaders who've commented
on it is yes it's ambitious it wants to
bring those waiting lists down because
every person on that
waiting list every statistic on that
waiting this is a real person with
health concerns but we've got to be
realistic about this we've got to be
honest with people
about the scale of that challenge um and
uh and the impact that will have both on
workload and on workforce so what we've
set is is what we think is ambitious but
realistic as a way to bring that waiting
list down and we want to be straight
with people about it okay your ultimate
boss prime minister's questions later on
today is he going to apologize for what
he said about uh kia stomach by the
prime minister it's now time the prime
minister kaye has been um frankly he's
clarified what he was talking about i
know colleagues of mine have been on had
this conversation with you in recent
days he's clarified that he was talking
about
sir
in the context of his leadership role
the c uh cps um just as quite rightly
shakir holds him to account for his
leadership role over the government that
doesn't mean personal responsibility for
individual decisions but that's the
context the prime minister has clarified
that okay let's take it and i'll be
honest with you i suspect that's that's
what you will hear from the prime
minister uh yeah do i take it from me
take it from the speaker this is what he
said yesterday
these sorts of comments only inflame
opinions and generate disregard for the
house and it is not acceptable
our words have consequences and we
should always be mindful of that fight
and he specifically slowed the leader of
the opposition didn't he well you heard
sir lindsay there they speak about words
having consequences they do and i think
all politicians all of us in the public
eye whether in media and politics and a
whole range of um sort of indeed
individuals on things like twitter and
need to think carefully about the words
we use i have no doubt that
after i come off this morning media
round i will go back to my own box and i
will receive threats and abuse that's
sadly what happens it shouldn't happen i
think everyone needs to reflect
carefully
those trolls are not the prime ministers
no i think everyone's speaking from the
district i think everyone needs to
reflect yeah specifically
he's specifically and he's well the
prime minister's clarified didn't he
though
the prime minister has clarified for you
what he said here we go
this leader of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions mr
speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile he he he was talking about
him not the position that he holds but
the prime minister's been clear that and
they clarified that i think on a few
days afterwards that he was referring to
him and he said he in the context of his
role as leader of an organization
from what we just heard that's what the
prime minister has been clear about
being clarified by that and you believe
the prime minister do you think that's
do you think that's let's just
okay let's just um let's just remind our
viewers um exactly what he said uh in
blackpool when he was clarifying the
situation
i'm talking not about
the leader of the opposition's personal
um record when he was uh when he was dpp
uh and i and i totally understand that
he had nothing to do uh personally with
those decisions
he was talking about the leader of the
opposition i just played you this went
in the context of his leadership with
the dpp and he had nothing personally do
with those decisions he was clear about
that it wasn't a personal point he was
making as the prime minister made clear
and as and kier quite rightly had said
he when he was dpp he took
responsibility for the successes and the
failures he was totally right about that
just as he's right say the prime
minister
as leader of the government takes
responsibility for all aspects of what
happens in government someone who was by
the prime minister's side for 12 years
resigned
as a direct result of what the prime
minister did and did not apologize
talking about meniera mirza of course
she wrote in her letter there was no
fair or reasonable basis for the
assertion this was not the normal cut
and thrust of politics it was an
inappropriate and partisan reference to
a horrendous case of child sex abuse she
decided to resign over it well i've
worked with munira in the past when she
was at city hall i'm in her previous
role and i have great respect for munir
i'm very sorry to see her go i think
she's a lady of great integrity and
great ability i'm sorry to see her go
but as i say i saw the prime minister's
clarification that he was clear that he
was referring to
uh secure in the context of leader of an
organization not personally
i accept that clarification but i would
come back to my domain which is of
course we do all need to be
mindful of the language we use as i
always seek to be when i come on your
show when i speak at the dispatch and
which we appreciate of course but julian
smith tobias ellwood robert lag and
sadiq khan who's on later on nicholas
sturgeon david lammy
ed davey
the wife of the husband forgive me of uh
joe cox who who was murdered all saying
that words have consequences the prime
minister why is it so hard for him to
apologize well i think you're right say
words have consequences and i think
that's why it was right the prime
minister clarified what he meant and was
very clear in that clarification i think
it was clear that he was not suggesting
any personal involvement by care i think
it's important that he made that
clarification and pleased that he did
make that clarification but i think he
was right to make it so
why is sorry such a difficult word for
this prime minister well i think this
prime minister has set out his his
position quickly he's clarified it he's
explained what he meant um with those
remarks he explained very clearly it
wasn't a personal
reference and i think that um that that
is an appropriate way for him to have
moved things forward
let's talk very briefly about this mini
shuffle reshuffle we disappointed you
weren't bumped up okay
javid's job
okay i've been um minister of state of
health i think i'm the longest-serving
minister of state health in 20 years i
think now alfred
and i suspect if i was in another role i
wouldn't get the opportunity so
frequently to come on your on your
program and do the morning round now
it's it's a huge privilege for me to be
minister of state health particularly
during a pandemic i've had the
opportunity it's very difficult times
and you and i have spoken on many
occasions but to work with some amazing
um people i like everyone else serve
wherever i'm asked to do my best for my
country in that context and it's been a
huge privilege and continues to be a
huge privilege to work with the nhs and
drive forward
our plans for the recovery of waiting
lists and support our nhs